my name is Jamie Lee Curtis and these
are some of my favorite behind the
scenes moments or BTS as the kids call
them from the Halloween movies
so the original Halloween movie was made
in 17 days it was so fast and I remember
shooting that sequence in that closet
with the louvered uh pieces of wood and
I think we did it like in an hour it was
shot so quickly I remember when the wire
hanger is there and that moment where
she grabs it and unspools it and kind of
Jabs at him and I I remember thinking
how smart Laurie Strode was I just
remember being impressed with her
Ingenuity in that really terrifying
moment and what would you do
if somebody was you know coming at you
in a closet in the intelligence of Lori
Strode figuring out that if you undo the
wire hanger and Jab him that it would
cause him maybe to either move away or
whatever and he drops the knife
obviously
um there are a couple knife drops in the
Halloween movie there's one earlier on
in the movie and then now this this last
sequence so when she stabs him which
again shows Laurie's Ingenuity and
intelligence but then there's the moment
immediately following it where she drops
the knife again which I kept saying to
John why is she throwing away the knife
and he said because she has to to finish
the movie basically because if he
doesn't have a knife there's no thread
so I remember also the incongruity of
that being like yeah this is great but
that seems like a really
stupid move
happy Halloween Michael
[Music]
so the idea that the plan the whole time
has been that we're going to trap
Michael that it was a we're going to
lure him into a position where we were
then going to entrap him and burn him it
was a you know obviously a very intense
sequence the kitchen fight was intense
and physical and painful
very painful but you know I remember
that it was also very gratifying that
the when you see a plan come together
and you know the Ingenuity even for the
special effects team of creating the way
that the basement gets sealed off with
those spy I mean everybody on the crew
was like told stay 25 feet away from
this because they were real spikes and
obviously they didn't want to trip it
too early so it was it was fun and
intense and you know a Halloween movie I
personally don't like special effects
and stunts because they're dangerous and
I've participated in a lot of special
effects and a lot of stunts obviously
the amount of security and safety and
safety briefings and planning and
support teams and support Personnel are
always
everywhere all the time there's so many
meetings and so much planning and yet at
some point you still light something on
fire and that's always
awesome and terrifying all at the same
time just the power of fire and that was
intense to see that much fire around
that house there are authorities who are
trained to deal with exactly this kind
of this
there's a system
well this system failed
now get the [ __ ] out of my way don't no
no no the filmmakers
um when they made the first movie
painted themselves into a very bloody
Corner because Lori sustains a serious
abdominal wound and basically is
bleeding out from that knife wound in
the back of the truck when the movie
ends
so when you pick up the next movie which
they hadn't planned in advance
and Lori is brought to the hospital in a
continuous time stamp
Lori has a terrible stomach wound and
you have to honor that in the movie and
in the storytelling and so the reality
is Lori was taken into surgery there's a
surgical scene they cut her open
and you know there's small dialogue in
the background saying like luckily it
didn't get a major artery or something
but she still has a terrible abdominal
wound and then she's in a hospital bed
and then at some point she's supposed to
get up and like start to run around a
bit and I'm a I'm I'm a practical actor
and I said well there's no way
she can move around like I've had
surgeries where I've had little
incisions this big and you can't move
let alone like a big stomach so we had
this whole conversation about how could
she she has to get something in her that
will make her not feel as pained
and we came up with the sequence where
her partner in the bed next to her is
getting a dose of something and she even
makes a comment like give him more dope
and you know injecting herself in the
stomach with what we assume is some sort
of painkiller uh at least gives you some
logic that she could then move around a
little bit but then as the rest of the
movie progresses I still I do some very
good stomach pain acting I'm just saying
they don't give Oscars for stomach pain
acting in horror movies but would have
won because I was really very very
impressive
thank you
come on let's go so this last movie
Halloween ends is a very emotional movie
um you know the second Halloween movie
was a horror film it was just grisly and
bloody and
body County this is much more like the
original Halloween
which was much more of a Thriller really
uh and less grisly and the roller
coaster of the new movie is that there's
a moment it takes place four years after
the last movie
so there is a moment where you believe
that maybe Lori Strode and the town of
Haddonfield are healing and that there
can be some healing and some chance of
moving on with their lives and you just
bring her right up to the top of the
roller coaster where you think maybe for
one second things are gonna work out and
then things don't work out and then
everything wrong and then it becomes a
fight to the end and the end battle is
in a kitchen between Michael Myers and
Lori Strode and it was about a week of
shooting and it was intense
and my only
commentary to the entire team was please
don't make it look like a movie fight
please
uh this has to be like a a street brawl
this needs to be
um
brutal and and not fancy and everything
has to be real and there's a sequence
where he he gets some power over her and
tries to put her hand down a garbage
disposal
uh because
so real who
who of us have not put something down
the garbage disposal and then gone to
retrieve it and then the whole thing of
like okay there's the switch it's not on
putting my hand down here you know
um so I just wanted to make sure that
that final sequence
felt real and Powerful
and scary and
um it does
[Applause]
I've been playing Lori Strode
for 44 years
and that last day was not a particularly
harrowing day it was a pretty simple
shoot day
but everybody knew was my last day and
the entire crew was there
and all the actors showed up
and it was
really emotional
it was powerful because
I am
I am her
and I've been her for a long time
and that
that relationship is the most important
professional relationship I will ever
have
and so ending a professional
relationship that's the most important
one of your life
is is powerful
and very bittersweet
and I will
I'm not going to cry here
I won't do it
but I have I have shed many a tear
because the people
who love her
love me
because I am her and I feel it from
people I feel it I feel the for whatever
reason people have
have leaned in and and really taken her
into their lives as their sister
and I feel like I have a really giant
family now
and it's hard to say goodbye to them